uh you know i've worked with clint
eastwood twice he's that way billy bob
thornton is another guy i've
collaborated with he's that way yeah
there's just something about it because
it's a respect of i'm prepared i'm
prepared and this is not only my time
but it's your time yeah and we gotta go
and you've hired me and i get it i've
also endured i don't really know if i
feel comfortable i've i've also been
around and been on sets where great big
name actors have
deliberately sabotaged the shooting
schedule
either
inadvertently or or purposely i i you
know but they have definitely taken
steps to slow down production because of
their own vanity and
process right
and that much and that's much with some
of the older actors that come from
that period of i don't want to give up
real estate to a certain individual and
i don't i want to dominate this
character and it's the character and
it's not me it's this and i don't like
this blocking it's all that kind of [ __ ]
you go like
oh boy and you kind of have to suck it
up and just go i don't think there's
time for that now in this day and age i
mean you work all the time now i think
people people hire you they come in and
they expect you to do your job yeah i
mean when i worked with clint eastwood
uh on uh uh flags of our fathers he
loved clint i worked with clint he's a
great what did you do i did this movie
called midnight in the garden good and
evil i had one big scene and that's
great yeah i loved him he was like this
was a great movie he was the best
director in terms of just like
he would just do your thing shoot it and
then you go
that was great just uh this take just
acknowledged the jury
that's all i need you to do
i go do you have anything else because
no how did you feel i go i felt great he
goes all right you want another one
he just and he and he wouldn't even say
action remember he would just say he
just go jack to jack green his dp and
you just do that rolling oh yeah motion
oh i loved i loved clint he was it was
such a great it was my first real movie
my friend love him well i got to tell
you i got to go back and watch that and
and i loved your impersonation of them
too by the way and and that's exactly
the scenario yeah i did uh uh um
neil mcdonough and i did a big neil he
was on here oh was he yeah i love neil i
love neil i love his uh love of
catholicism yeah oh yeah he's got a
beautiful family he's a wonderful
wonderful guy
um
we were doing the outline uh uh the uh
parameters of the invasion of iwo jima
on this uh on the uss merchant marine
ship that's down there in the
long beach i can't remember the name of
the [ __ ] boat anyway and they
literally took it out and sailed it
around to catalina we were out in the
pacific ocean sailing around a boat with
a bunch of extras and
it was a lot of dialogue and i had just
done a lot of dialogue for david mammoth
the day before on my tv show the unit so
i was like double duty with two
monologues and i was a little concerned
that
[ __ ] can you do this well some of the
other stuff was bleeding into some of
the other stuff and i was starting to
get confused because there was some
numbers and there was some i got a
blackboard
where they were going to shoot the scene
and i'm kind of like referencing and i'm
kind of running the lines and kind of
and there's you know just all these
extras and reason
[ __ ] dude
i had a real that was probably the most
anxious i've ever been but i bet you he
relaxed you
well i was doing it you know alexander
techniques and breathing and you know
breathing with your [ __ ] and you know
you got to kind of breathe through your
feet and you got to squeeze your butt
cheeks i'm doing it now you got to think
about those you got to do all that [ __ ]
you really do yeah yeah and you're
sucking it in and you're kind of going
and it's exhausting you're exhausted in
those days yeah when you're nervous or
when you're going through all that stuff
the exhaustion just piles up on oh man
it's the worst piles on and you and
these young actors like uh paul walker
and all these guys are looking at you
like yeah these guys are [ __ ] fats
man they know what the [ __ ] they're
doing
and you're like yeah well and i i did go
up the second take but anyway the first
take the first day we got to was
flawless and they applauded and it was
two cameras far back and then clint
moved him up and he didn't come up to
him and he finally now he's he's walking
i've never really met him and he he says
to me and neal he goes yeah i've never
really been able to do those monologues
like that
i really admire you guys for wow that's
that's not easy you did a nice job
it was it was actually that's awesome it
was really really cool it was
self-deprecating and i admire you for
that and
you